someone on instagram he he called me a
slapper what's his instagram so we could
tell him to suck his mum my name is
angel my name is katarina my name is
esther my name is inauda i'm imogen now
big man senior we live in a world full
of clout chases bravo and i'm sick of it
what's your favorite feature on me i
think your personality that's not a
future bev
i look good like i know you want me
so you don't mind if a woman saw that no
that might make you even better i feel
like i'm climbing a tree
you seem very very genuine but it could
be with smoke and mirrors is it smoking
mirrors
when you're looking for a guy there's
the money matter but that doesn't stop
me from loving somebody the right way
and i'm gonna try and find out if the
girl them are here for the money and
clown or they're there for real love bro
so sloppy this is wild um yes who knows
what people are these days you get me
shout out to the non-binary people bro
because we don't know stormzy i do
actually love his stuff what's your
favorite stormzy song the one that
started everything i don't even know
that
do you think i'm a couch chaser do i
look like a clown chaser
yeah
i'm going to be telling you a lot to
step forward and i'm going to be
eliminating one by one let's tell that
you're on some [ __ ] and you're
trying to trick me so i see right
through you
the beautiful lady that i would like to
choose
is
big man ting this is clout chasers breve